while no one wants their favorite show
to end if it has to happen we all hope
the conclusion leaves us feeling
satisfied in some way
unfortunately some shows left their fans
confused disappointed angry and asking
questions this spoiler-filled list will
show you why
creator vince gilligan admitted that the
critically acclaimed season 5 felina
episode would probably be different from
what many breaking bad fans imagined and
would therefore disappoint a fair number
of people but it ended up giving most of
its characters satisfying endings that
fans loved the biggest lingering
question wasn't really about the end
itself but about how it all began the
show traces every inch of walter white's
transformation with brutal precision
what's missing is its true beginning
which is indirectly what made the ending
so meaningful
by blackmailing his old partners at gray
matter walt achieves what he set out to
do in the very first episode provide for
his family in the event of his demise
but we never really find out why he's
separated from them in the first place
choosing a life as a science teacher
over a lucrative career as a chemist
instead we get multiple versions of the
story walt's account suggests a
justifiable origin for the bitterness
that eventually led him to become a
criminal mastermind gretchen however
insists he left without an explanation
walt's journey from schoolteacher to
drug lord gets a lot of emphasis and
rightly so but given that it's
potentially the impetus for his eventual
life of crime the transformation from
all-star chemist to schoolteacher is one
we're really left wondering about
you knew this one was going to be on the
list in addition to devastating fans the
finale of how i met your mother left a
lot of things uncertain first of all
what kind of terminal illness did the
mother have that could have come on so
suddenly with such a poor prognosis
while not seeming to affect her youth
and radiance in any way as if the
mother's cruel demise wasn't bad enough
what happened to her rock band a pretty
significant plot point that introduced
tracy's character was the fact that ted
inadvertently helped her get her band
back from a usurper
it was a big moment for both tracy and
ted as a couple did the band ever make
it and speaking of character and
relationship development we know ted
left the wedding mid-reception but he
met tracy the bassist for the wedding
band at the platform did she a paid
performer for the whole evening suddenly
dip out too
and speaking of dipping out ted would
have been unemployed when he started
dating tracy because he quit his new
position in chicago to stay in new york
with her
but even hopeless romantics have to pay
their bills so what's up with that
perhaps the greatest injustice of the
series however was the fact that we
never did find out where ted got that
pineapple
ironically the title of lost aptly
describes what happened to the thread of
the famous audi series which was
complexly woven to begin with
the lost timeline was often hard to
follow even before the finale but fans
by and large had fun with the twists and
turns and they trusted that the writers
would tie it all up in the end this
happened for some loose ends but many
seemed to be forgotten or suddenly
changed from the inconsistent rules of
the island to walt's mysterious special
abilities there are a plethora of plot
devices that lost seemed to never fully
address or simply ignore completely not
to mention the bomb that was supposedly
the only hope for destroying the island
after detonating it a new and confusing
timeline is created but the bomb is
never really mentioned again and the
island isn't destroyed did jack and his
friends accomplish anything by setting
off the bomb we can't be sure similarly
we're never sure where the others money
comes from or what's going on with ben's
childhood friend annie who was supposed
to be a major part of the series lost
had a lot of loose ends to tie up to be
fair but we definitely expected more
even jerry seinfeld himself has admitted
he's had second thoughts over the years
following the seinfeld finale fans have
a lot more than just second thoughts
they've been thinking opining and
arguing about the final episode with
fervor ever since it aired in 1998.
there are loads of questions left
unanswered in the finale both about the
show as a whole and the episode itself
there are a few little details left
hanging for example what became of
george and jerry's show that was
supposed to take off in the last episode
before they got arrested did they work
on it in prison and perhaps most
importantly did jerry get the prisoners
to laugh at his routine
and there were a lot of bigger questions
too realistically how were all those
witnesses at the trial tracked down and
gathered from the last nine years of the
characters lives
legally how relevant or admissible would
their widely ranging character
testimonies even be and speaking of
evidence did rey steal the statue or not
the finale didn't make sense for a lot
of reasons both in terms of ambiguity as
to how and why it all happened as well
as in terms of how out of character it
was for the four friends in the show
pretty little liars was soapy from start
to finish but that doesn't mean the
ending was clean to be fair a lot of
questions were answered most importantly
the identity of a.d true to soap opera
form an evil identical twin
but as is often the case with plot
twists the big reveal answered some
questions only to open a pandora's box
of new ones you're still playing the
game one of the biggest unanswered
questions is how the wine moms escaped
from the basement
apparently only they will ever know the
true story also unknown to us how did
mona get mary and alex out of prison and
all the way to her basement in paris
after everything she's gone through
maybe it's better not to ask questions
and just let her be happy
hbo's revolutionary mafia series the
sopranos featured a flawed anti-hero and
allowed its characters room for
realistic evolution and devolution
but for all the masterful depictions of
tony soprano's character the series left
us unsure of how his story ended
some have called this finale episode
revolutionary while others upon its
conclusion got up to check whether their
tv sets were broken
we suspect that the cut to black is the
moment of death that bobby baccalieri
once imagined as likely being
anticlimactic you probably don't even
hear it when it happens
a cut to black is the perfect way to
illustrate that if tony were off by the
stranger who heads to the bathroom
earlier in the scene it would mirror one
of his favorite parts of the godfather
that is michael corleone emerging from
the restaurant bathroom to kill solazzo
and captain mccluskey
not only were we left without the
details of tony's fate but we never got
to see what happened to characters like
silvio dante a compelling character who
lies comatose for the entire final
episode as a result of his gunshot
wounds
dexter was supposed to end with the
death of its titular serial killer but
the actual finale neither redeemed nor
condemned its protagonist literally
running away from the jarring moral
tension it has introduced in episode 1.
what exactly went wrong
well the series spent eight seasons
developing dexter as a calculating and
methodical force
then in the finale he decides to
disappear leaving his son in the company
of a known murderer in order to live a
fake life as a lumberjack fans can't
help but feel that this was forced and
out of character not only that but we're
also left with a genuine lack of
resolution what happens to dexter's son
after being abandoned by his father sure
he left harrison in hannah's care but
not legally so in the eyes of the u.s
hannah simply abducted him to argentina
and how did dexter even survive that
storm in the first place without so much
as a scratch and what was the reason for
choosing oregon as the location of his
life in hiding knowing dexter he would
have had one
the ending of true blood may have given
it eternal life but not necessarily in a
desirable way for many people it will
forever be immortalized as an incident
of what went wrong
the ending to this series didn't seem to
have its finger on the pulse or lack
thereof while some complaints simply
revolved around it being boring there
were some very real questions left
unanswered after letting fans get
invested enough to choose sides
regarding who suki would end up with
both team eric and team bill were left
disappointed suki ends up marrying some
rando who only gets a few seconds of
screen time in the finale seriously who
is this guy we also never find out who
turned steve newland or the identity of
pam's first progeny who we never got to
meet
at the end of the series we're left with
many questions about the characters that
were left unanswered and some answers
that just don't quite make sense
while game of thrones left multiple
lingering questions the biggest one is
simply why
and that question applies to a lot for
some fans it applies not just to the
finale but the whole of the eighth
season we're especially looking at you
suddenly crazy daenerys
but issues with writing and development
aside we're still left wondering about
all manner of things
why did jon have to kill dany rather
than arya who was not only an expertly
trained assassin but was planning to go
awol anyway and honestly why didn't
daenerys have better security after
taking the throne
why exactly was bran the logical choice
to become king
and how do we explain daenerys massive
army in the finale didn't she lose most
of her unsullied and dothraki forces
back in the battle at winterfell
finally when bran agrees to become king
he implies that he came quote all this
way for that exact purpose
this suggests that he knew much more
about the future than he previously led
on like when he insisted earlier that he
couldn't be lord of winterfell
sadly the highly anticipated finale left
many confusing and exasperating
questions making it seem like the
writers just punted
the maddest men and women in 2015 were
the fans of one of amc's most successful
dramas and its jaded male anti-hero don
draper
some mad men viewers felt angry at the
conclusion while for others the finale
simply generated a mountain of questions
the show did an impeccable job of
portraying a flawed and troubled soul as
well as the people who helped shape him
into the formidable madman that he was
but one of the biggest unanswered
questions involves some of those very
side characters particularly don
draper's family who undoubtedly bore the
brunt of his bad behavior for many years
but we don't hear from donner henry
francis after betty's death regarding
who'll take custody of don's children
after all his family has endured from
him we have no idea what will become of
them
messed everything up
but even more than the draper family
fans want to know what happened to don
he seems to achieve inner peace at the
end but not in the form of some grand
transformation
all inner peace really means to him it
seems is coming up with the next great
ad
but while it's a hollow idea of
happiness it's also not conclusive maybe
he just makes that one last great ad and
then steps back to finally take care of
his family hard to believe but the
ambiguity lets us wonder
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you